Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter One, Episode Four: the German occupation, the Cold War, the growth of the welfare state, and the youth revolt, from 1940 to 1972.
In September 1939, Hitler's attack on Poland led Great Britain and France to declare war on Germany.
The Second World War had broken out in Europe.
Denmark was occupied by Germany from 1940 until the end of the war in 1945.
Denmark cooperated with the Germans to soften the terms of the occupation.
But during the war a Danish resistance movement grew up.
And at the same time, Denmark succeeded in saving the vast majority of the country's Jews from Nazi Germany's genocide, the Holocaust.
Let's start on the morning it happened.
Denmark and Norway were attacked and occupied by the German military on the ninth of April, 1940.
The German explanation was that Germany wanted to protect the two countries against a British occupation.
But Germany's occupation of Denmark was mainly because it was interested in Norway.
German warfare depended on deliveries of iron ore from Northern Sweden, which was to be shipped out through the town of Narvik on the ice-free Norwegian Atlantic coast.
The British had also shown interest in that supply of raw materials.
In addition, Germany wanted its access to the world's oceans secured via Norway's long coast.
Since Denmark is the country that lies between Norway and Germany, the Germans needed access to the airfield in Aalborg as a stopover.
Finally, Denmark's position on the North Sea made the country an indispensable part of the German defence against a possible Allied invasion of the European west coast.
Early in the morning of the ninth of April, the attack began, as German troops crossed the border in South Jutland.
Denmark's military resistance to the attack was insignificant and lasted only a few hours.
This meant that only a few Danish soldiers lost their lives in the attack.
Germany's military power was so great that the government did not think it would be of any use to continue resisting.
Germany demanded that Denmark should cooperate with the occupying power.
Denmark agreed to this out of necessity.
The Danish government was not deposed, but continued as a coalition government under Social Democratic leadership, though under German control.
The king also continued as regent.
Formally, Denmark kept its status as a sovereign, neutral state, even though the country was occupied by German troops.
And for most Danes, at least the first years of the occupation, life continued largely without big changes.
On the tenth of May, 1940, one month after the Danish surrender, France was also invaded by Germany, which defeated the French forces in less than six weeks.
This left Great Britain almost alone in the fight against Hitler, and an Allied victory seemed far away.
But German warfare met increasing problems as the years went by, and more and more people began to believe in an Allied victory.
Two events in 1941 were decisive in this connection.
One was Germany's invasion, Operation Barbarossa, of the Soviet Union on the twenty-second of June.
The other, when Japan, which was on Germany's side in the war, bombed the American fleet at Pearl Harbor in Hawaii in the Pacific on the seventh of December.
Thereby both the Soviet Union and the USA were drawn into the war on the Allied side, and Germany had gained too many and too strong enemies for it to be possible to win the war in the long run.
In the first years of the occupation, there was relative calm in Denmark in spite of the war.
But from 1942, the Danes' resistance to the German presence in the country began to grow.
The Germans thought neither that the Danish government did enough to crush this resistance, nor that it otherwise helped secure German interests in the country.
After a major crisis in the Danish-German relationship in October 1942, a new government was formed at German demand, led by Erik Scavenius, a former foreign minister and a strong advocate of the policy of cooperation with Germany.
In August 1943, when it was becoming more and more clear that Germany would lose the war, big strikes broke out in several Danish towns as a result of ever harsher German demands.
On the twenty-ninth of August, 1943, the government decided to submit its resignation to the king, after Scavenius had rejected the Germans' demand to intervene actively against the strikes and the ever-growing resistance to the German occupation, including the German demand for the death penalty for sabotage.
This ended the Danish government's policy of cooperation with Nazi Germany.
The German occupying power at the same time dissolved the Danish military.
The Danish navy itself sank most of its ships in 1943, so that they would not fall into German hands.
After that, Denmark in reality had no government, even though the king had refused to accept the government's resignation.
In practice, the country was afterwards run by the permanent secretaries, the departementschefer, the ministries' top administrative heads.
They continued, to a certain extent and more informally, the coordination with the German occupying power, to protect the population as much as possible despite the new and more serious situation in the country.
Now to the rescue.
In 1940, about eight thousand Jews lived in Denmark.
More than seven thousand of them managed to flee the Nazis' persecution during the occupation.
Most were helped to Sweden by fellow Danish citizens, just before the Germans tried to arrest the Danish Jews in October 1943.
Up to five hundred Danish Jews were, however, sent to concentration camps in Germany, where many died.
On a European scale, a very large share of the Danish Jews survived this genocide, which is also known as the Holocaust.
In total, Nazi Germany murdered six million of Europe's roughly nine to ten million Jews during the war, most by mass shootings or in gas chambers in extermination camps.
And a different part of the kingdom took its own path in these years.
In 1944, Iceland broke away for good after 564 years under Denmark.
In the second half of the 1800s a strong independence movement arose in Iceland, which in 1918, with the so-called Act of Union, had gained extensive self-government in a federation, a personal union, with Denmark.
That means the Danish king was also king of Iceland.
Further, Iceland's foreign and defence policy was handled by Denmark.
During the Second World War, Iceland's geographical position in the middle of the northern Atlantic took on great importance.
Planes and ships on the way from the USA to Europe could use the island as a base.
Great Britain therefore occupied Iceland in May 1940, to prevent a German invasion.
Later in the war, the USA took over the defence of the Icelandic area.
The Act of Union from 1918 expired in 1943, and Denmark, being under German occupation, had no real possibility to renegotiate it.
In a referendum, an almost unanimous Icelandic population decided on full independence.
The Republic of Iceland was proclaimed on the seventeenth of June, 1944, which therefore became Iceland's national day.
Back in Denmark, the last years of the occupation were marked by more and more acts of sabotage, both against the German military in Denmark and against the Danes who cooperated with the occupying power.
The Freedom Council, Frihedsrådet, was established in September 1943.
It was an illegal committee in which the leaders of the various resistance movements coordinated the resistance against the German occupying power.
A big strike in Copenhagen in July 1944 gave rise to increased contact between the resistance movement and politicians.
After the strike, the Freedom Council and the Danish politicians cooperated to get Denmark recognised as an ally in the fight against Germany.
The Soviet Union opposed this, however.
In the spring of 1945, Nazi Germany collapsed after hard fighting in Europe.
On the fifth of May, Denmark was officially liberated by British forces, after the German troops had surrendered.
On Bornholm, however, the Germans refused to surrender.
In the last days of the occupation, the island was therefore attacked by Soviet forces, who stayed on the island until the spring of 1946.
In total, about seven thousand Danes were killed during the Second World War, many of them seamen who sailed in Allied war service.
Denmark was thus not as hard hit by the Second World War as many other European countries.
With about sixty million dead worldwide, the Second World War is the bloodiest war in world history, and the death toll was far higher in almost all other German-occupied countries.
For example, the Netherlands lost about two hundred thousand citizens, and in Eastern Europe, where the war was far bloodier than in Western Europe, Poland alone lost five to six million citizens.
The relatively low death toll and limited destruction are due, first, to the quick Danish surrender in April 1940 and the subsequent policy of cooperation with the Germans.
Second, it is because the German troops in Denmark, apart from those on Bornholm, surrendered without a fight at the end of the war in 1945, even before the Allied forces arrived in the country.
The war's main battles between the great powers thus never reached Denmark.
There was, however, a shortage of many goods in Denmark.
To control consumption, and to distribute the scarce supplies to everyone, so-called rationing was introduced for, for example, petrol, gas, electricity, sugar, coffee, tea, flour, bread, soap, meat and butter.
It meant that each citizen could only buy a limited amount of these goods.
Several of the winters during the occupation were unusually cold, with temperatures down to minus thirty degrees, and the lack of fuel, for example oil and coal, made it hard to heat homes, schools and workplaces.
But unlike in many other countries, there was never famine in Denmark.
The political system also survived the war.
The resistance movement gained a certain political influence in the time right after the liberation, but the old politicians and parties quickly returned to power.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
How long did Denmark's official military resistance last when Germany attacked on the ninth of April 1940?
Option A: Less than a day.
Option B: Between one and two weeks.
Option C: About a month and a half.
[DA] Hvor længe varede Danmarks officielle militære modstand, da Tyskland angreb Danmark den 9. april 1940?  A: Mindre end en dag  |  B: Mellem en og to uger  |  C: Cirka halvanden måned
The answer is A: Less than a day.
It appeared in the June 2022 and November 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Mindre end en dag
Question 2.
In which year did the Danish government's cooperation policy with the German occupying power end?
Option A: 1941.
Option B: 1943.
Option C: 1945.
[DA] Hvilket år ophørte den danske regerings samarbejdspolitik med den tyske besættelsesmagt under 2. Verdenskrig?  A: 1941  |  B: 1943  |  C: 1945
The answer is B: 1943.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: 1943
Question 3.
When did the Danish government's cooperation policy with Germany take place during the Second World War?
Option A: 1940 to 43.
Option B: 1943 to 45.
[DA] Hvornår fandt den danske regerings samarbejdspolitik med Tyskland under 2. Verdenskrig sted?  A: 1940-43  |  B: 1943-45
The answer is A: 1940 to 43.
It appeared in the May 2024 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: 1940-43
Question 4.
Which group of citizens was helped, in their thousands, to flee from Denmark to Sweden in October 1943?
Option A: Danish communists.
Option B: Danish soldiers.
Option C: Danish Jews.
[DA] Hvilken gruppe borgere blev i tusindtal hjulpet med at flygte fra Danmark til Sverige i oktober 1943?  A: Danske kommunister  |  B: Danske soldater  |  C: Danske jøder
The answer is C: Danish Jews.
It appeared in the November 2020 and November 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Danske jøder
Question 5.
When was it decided by a referendum in Iceland to establish an independent republic, independent of Denmark?
Option A: 1901.
Option B: 1918.
Option C: 1944.
[DA] Hvornår blev det ved en folkeafstemning i Island besluttet at oprette en selvstændig republik uafhængig af Danmark?  A: 1901  |  B: 1918  |  C: 1944
The answer is C: 1944.
It appeared in the November 2020, May 2023 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: 1944
Question 6.
On which date is Denmark's liberation in 1945, after five years of German occupation, marked?
Option A: The eighth of March.
Option B: The ninth of April.
Option C: The fifth of May.
[DA] På hvilken dato markeres Danmarks befrielse i 1945 efter fem års tysk besættelse?  A: 8. marts  |  B: 9. april  |  C: 5. maj
The answer is C: The fifth of May.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: 5. maj
That's the end of Part One of Episode 4.
In Part Two, we continue with the Cold War, the welfare state and the youth revolt.
See you there.